what is a raincloud plot a raincloud
plot is a data visualization tool that
provides a comprehensive view of a data
set by combining several plots into one
figure it essentially brings together
the power of a box plot a violin plot
and a strip or swarm plot making it
easier to understand both the overall
distribution and the raw data of a given
variable or group but what are the
components of a raincloud plot Number
One Cloud the cloud in the raincloud
plot is a rotated and horizontally
aligned kernel density estimation
similar to a violin plot that shows the
distribution density of the data it
provides insights into the shape of the
data distribution highlighting areas of
higher density number two rain strip or
swamp plot the rain consists of
individual data points or raw data
represented as dots this part of the
plot shows each data point giving a
clear view of the raw data number three
box plot often there's a traditional box
plot showing the median and Inter
quarter range this provides summary
statistics about the data's central
tendency spread and potential outliers
the raincloud plot is particularly
useful because it offers a holistic view
of the data allowing for the
appreciation of the distribution shape
the raw data points and summary
statistics all in one visualization this
can be especially helpful when comparing
distributions across multiple groups or
conditions if you like you can create a
raincloud plot for free online using
data tab just go to data.net and copy
your own data into this table then click
on either descriptive or charts further
simply select your variables if you now
scroll down you will be presented with
many charts that could be suitable for
the data including the raincloud plot
let's take a closer look at this example
let's say we want to analyze patient
recover recovery times in days after
surgery across various age groups here
are our data with the recovery time and
the three age groups young adults
middle-aged and seniors now we can
display the data in a raincloud plot
let's have a look at young adults the
recovery times range between 4 to 8 days
with a higher concentration around 5 to
6 days this indicates quicker recovery
and is visualized as a broad section in
the middle of the violin plot in the
same way we can interpret the results of
middle-aged and seniors thanks for
watching and I hope you enjoyed the
video